bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on l'a vu
précédemment avec les participants à la
marche de cet après midi mais pas
seulement la reconnaissance de clive
inexcusable par emmanuel macron n'est
pas satisfaisante à leurs yeux est ce
également votre avis kader abderrahim
est pourquoi
mais il
faut saluer les progrès accomplis depuis
maintenant quinze à vingt ans par les
différents présidents français qui se
sont succédé les choses sont allées
crescendo
avec malheureusement on est quand même
obligé de le relever est de le constater
un travail qui se fait à semi parce que
du côté de l'algérie il n'y a pas autant
de liberté ni d'action ni de réflexion
on tentait de écrire l'histoire est-ce
que c'est suffisant certainement pas
mais on progresse et c'est ça qu'il faut
noter je crois qu'on est plus dans le
déni mais il y a encore des choses qui
sont dissimulés voir cacher et cela
prendra du temps et il faut pas se faire
d'illusions mais pour autant je crois
que génération après génération
se fait et émerge la réalité des faits
est une vérité historique qui est
incontestable qu'est ce qui est caché
dissimulé selon vous kader anaheim
et bien écoutez on ne sait pas pour le
moment par exemple je relève que le
président maquereau a procédé de la même
manière hier qu'elle son prédécesseur
françois hollande un simple communiqué
party de l'elysée on m'a pas vu le
président français se rendre sur le pont
de bezons ou à saint michel ou bien même
en me disant à rendre hommage il faut
aussi à le souligner
pardon il a aussi été tout de même été
le premier président à rendre hommage
lors de des commémorations qui ont eu
lieu hier il faut quand même souligner
tout à fait oui il arrête il a fait un
communiqué et il s'est rendu
physiquement sur le pont de bezons ce
que n'avait pas fait son prédécesseur il
ya simplement voulu communiquer et
marquer cette date symbolique est
importante à la fois pour la france et
pour l'algérie mais l'un et l'autre ne
vont pas encore il y a encore des
résistances des réticences et puis
n'oublions pas que en france nous sommes
en pleine période de pré campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle
et que m nl mac os mobile tenir compte
de toutes les sensibilités
rappelons qu'il y a entre 8 et 10 % des
citoyens de français qui ont une
ascendance algérienne ou qui ont un lien
direct avec la guerre d'algérie et donc
il ya encore des sensibilités qui sont
assez son abîme pourquoi selon vous
kader abderrahim la france est elle
réticente à l'idée de qualifier ces
répressions meurtrières de crime d'état
comme le demande on l'a vu des
organisations des associations et
d'autres personnes encore
parce que cela implique un engagement
politique et il me semble à ce stade
emmanuel macron préfère garantir sa
réélection
et puis peut-être que dans un an de
notre euro le 17 octobre
2022 pour évoquer peut-être une
évolution dans le vocabulaire et puis
cela puisque également des enquêtes
la réconciliation est en marche c'est
une très bonne chose toutefois impôts il
faut qu'elle s'accompagne de la justice
et il faut que les responsabilités
soient clairement établies et ça c'est
le travail et le rose de la justice ce
ne peut pas être le rôle du président de
la république justement vous les vieux
qui y est aussi tout à l'heure dans le
communiqué de ligne et transmis hier
toute la responsabilité a été imputée à
maurice papon pourtant il était lui même
sous l'autorité directe du ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque à savoir roger
frey
oui on était haut le contexte on était
en pleine guerre d'algérie une fin de
guerre qui a été terrible et les
négociations avec le fln était
compliquée et difficile et appelons
également que
toute la france gaulliste et le
gouvernement français ont fermé les yeux
sur les responsabilités directes de
maurice papon lorsqu'il était secrétaire
général de la préfecture de la gironde
et qu'il a participé à ce gala à la
place où il était à la déportation de
juifs français donc il ya une complicité
du silence qui s'est établie et il était
très difficile pour le général du maul
qui était chef de l'état à ce moment là
et qui négocier avec le fln
l'indépendance d'établir ou de
reconnaître cette responsabilité de
l'état français dans les massacres de
sharon vous voulu ramener ce contexte et
justement on le rappelle aussi c'est une
manifestation du 17 octobre 1961 qui a
été organisée à l'appel du fln elle
était donc destinée à dénoncer un
couvre-feu discriminatoire est ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler dans quel
contexte ce couvre-feu a été mise en
place et pourquoi il cibler
spécifiquement des français musulmans
d'algérie
et bien parce que les dirigeants du fln
à tunis absolument persuadé que ce que
l'on a appelé la fédération de france
c'est-à-dire l'émanation du fln sur le
territoire dans l'hexagone avec les
algériens qui vivaient en france pouvait
jouer un rôle important en exerçant une
pression sur le gouvernement sur les
autorités françaises
de manière à parvenir a pas de bonnes
négociations favorable en tout cas aux
revendications du fln et c'est dans ce
contexte très singulier particulier que
la fédération de france du fln alors si
cet appel à la manifestation de charonne
et rappelons également je pense que ça
viendra un peu plus tard mais il ya
octobre 61 et puis il ya février 1962 à
l'appel du parti communiste lorsque les
communistes français la gauche en
général
manifeste pour contre la le sort qui est
fait aux algériens de france il y a là
aussi d'une répression qui s'exerce et
et tous ceux qui poussent pour
contribuer à la dégradation des
relations entre les communautés de
françaises et algériennes
lorsqu'elles sont sur le territoire
français ont contribué à une dégradation
des rapports qui se sont au fil du temps
considérablement étiolé et qui sont au
point mort ou au stade où nous sommes
arrivés aujourd'hui entre les deux pays
merci beaucoup kader abderrahim je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à sciences po directeur de
recherche à l'ipc et auteur du livre
géopolitique de l'algérie aux éditions
bibiloni merci à vous